l'information était au coeur des
discussions ce matin à rivière salée
depuis deux ans chacun se demande où se
trouve au de jean alexis la jeune femme
a disparu en novembre 2010 est alors
qu'elle se rendait au travail laisse
aller en tout imaginer et ils apprennent
maintenant que le suspect arrêté vite
aussi au quartier là haut tout comme la
jeune femme et un bus c'était le premier
suspect après deux ans on trouve comme
pas qui a fait ça c'est dégueulasse en
fait il avait disparu ailleurs que grâce
à lui qu'on fait ou une jeune le vt unac
avait la vie devant elle et puis que se
soit passé comme ça d'autant plus
c'était pas loin donc ces quelques
peut-être qui la connaissaient qui
essayait peut-être de la cour disait
déjà mais sans le savoir je sais pas de
nombreuses interrogations auxquelles
cette arrestation pour répondre le
suspect de 42 ans avait pris en stop le
jour de sa disparition et l'adn de la
jeune femme a été retrouvé sur des
menottes saisis chez lui lors d'une
perquisition des éléments troublants qui
plonge les salaires dans l'effroi je
suis maman de deux filles c'est une
douleur qui a été très profond pour moi
parce que ne pas retrouver leurs corps
pour faire leur deuil de sa fille on
imagine que plage surtout c'est quelque
chose de déplorable pour l'instant la
justice fait son travail
on ne sait pas exactement ce qui s'est
passé donc je ne vais pas me prononcer
là-dessus mais je dirais que ça va être
difficile pour les parents et puis le
touquet à rui dos tu perds je suis avec
l'auteur j'ai six filles et aussi et je
trouve que c'est un petit peu
désagréable mais qu'est ce que je peux
dire que ça mercus tonnes est au bout le
suspect a été mis en examen pour
arrestation enlèvement et séquestration
suivis de mort il a été placé en
détention provisoire
les investigations se poursuivent pour
éclaircir
de nombreuses zones d'ombré